whoever wins the most of this this
little war we got going on whoever wins
the most chips basketball is headed in
that style the kids are going to either
continue to go to the post and want to
shoot fadeaways
or they don't think this [ __ ] okay
they're shooting this [ __ ] from half
course [ __ ] i remember being switched
like man he wanna shoot that [ __ ] before
he let him shoot that [ __ ] for 40 [ __ ]
him like that's what we that's how i'm
feeling when i'm really on the court
like hey go ahead let him bro i wish you
would pull it
pull that bro please but we can run this
down y'all throw like please shoot that
yeah that's how we felt about it until
this little [ __ ] started making
it now t lu looking at us at the drawing
board like hey y'all gonna get out there
shut up what we gonna do
you shocked yeah you shocked me making
it now like it got it got to that point
it's like bro i keep saying basketball
changed
like they ruined it type of thing but
i'm like you ruined the version that i
like how basketball it is today it's
scary how good they are